good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials I was about to
roughen the midden want to like ruffle
ruffle Theo's feathers cos here today
he's hopefully gonna be a good boy he's
on the couch I'm our casting couch it's
been just so long since I've been here
but even longer since Theo's been here I
know I'm so happy to have my wish you
guys could see him he's being a precious
gem of a man of a curious smelly man
once we get through it like a maybe 75%
of the show I'll bring him on but you
know he can see a little bit of much
would you like all of our guests yeah
exactly give him the respect he deserved
for sure well hello everyone my name is
Claudia Austria I'm so glad to be back
in case you forgot what I looked like
because there were two shows without me
where I had incredible FOMO therefore I
did not watch we actually also podcasts
oh right I forgot Jackie one time just
for a weekend it was the wedding that
never ended right my friend on a guy
married in Mexico this weekend it was
just such a jolly good time except I'm
[ __ ] exhausted and I'm so sore my ass
cheeks like are so sore and I can't
decide if it's from like getting down on
the dance floor all night long like for
a couple what is he doing he's just
saying hey good job mom you're killing
it good mornin Millennials I can't
decide if my sore ass cheeks are from
getting down on the dance floor
night after night or from Maya Kobo's
revenge what was that called
Montezuma's revenge's Nima's revenge I
Charlotte York pick hip seed in my pants
except not in my pants I did think I
drink some tap water and it did not sit
well with me I woke up in the middle of
the night like literally I thought I was
gonna die I'm so glad you did it and
that you're here yeah Montezuma that
would be so sad on Theo I know you just
never came home no but so being reunited
with Theo like I hate leaving but I love
coming back so it's like you can't come
back if you never left
no absence makes the heart grow fonder
yes or be played out of mind
well I have a feeling I don't know if
I'm that influential but maybe we have
some a couple of new toasters because I
did like a big master post on the girl
with no job Instagram last night because
I just felt like maybe there's a big
Theo cuz she's angel man how dare you
your mother is speaking he wants me on
the show he has something to say Jackie
we all have something to say and my
thing that I was trying to say is that
where you were brutally interrupted by
my son nonetheless the lack of respect
in my house is just it's so apparent
look
I can't even take him out I mean he's a
friend reflection I'm healing your
parenting skills [ __ ] that is so rude
just something to think about well what
I was trying to say is that I did bring
that store poster girl to a job but
maybe some of the girls lunch up
followers don't know about the toast so
maybe they're here watching if you're
here on the YouTube stream like watching
because I told you to laughs and on my
girl with no job Instagram like let me
know okay cool I just I mean I got some
followers so I didn't hate it did you I
did influence sprinkling it around and
they went private like midway through
the Ascension because I was like no you
don't just get this for free how was
your weekend
my weekend was swell what did I do I
really laid low but I wasn't like too
low you know you know you ever have
weekends where you literally don't see
the sunlight you mean the great that's
really it was what a weekend should be
right it wasn't one of those like each
day I saw the Sun I saw the Sun what is
the sign of a Sun and so it was nice I
had a hate good SUP good I'm so jealous
I didn't sleep at all the super bowl
happened oh yeah well it was during the
wedding and honest so funny like she
totally doesn't care about the wedding I
mean about the Super Bowl but like a lot
of people there did but it was in this
like we had to drive like a little up
north I guess I don't know South it
could have been anyway but there was no
cell phone call there was definitely
warmer there was no cell phone service
so like people like couldn't check the
Super Bowl so like it's not like she
didn't let them they just like couldn't
you know where people freaking out was
when well so there was a vent Wi-Fi that
was locked because like the production
they needed Wi-Fi for like the music and
everything so obviously been found a way
to get the password and we hadn't been
had it the whole time like everyone was
like freaking out like me in bed and
like we were really like the 1% you know
like we had it we didn't give it to
anyone because if we gave it to everyone
I wouldn't have worked well right so he
you guys knew what was going on in the
cblol and we did about nothing Ben kept
updating the groom on the score even
though I don't think he cared but like
every now and then Ben would like oh my
word is here like rounds three out good
thing there was no update yeah it was
the lowest going scoring Super Bowl in
history he's a true mm-hmm drama drama
either that means like everyone was
really good where everyone was really
bad well I think you know both teams
played really defensively
so it's hard to score on that but they
also played very shittily
teams and how did Ben feel that his son
was rooting for the Rams I knew that was
a controversial choice oh did you put on
the girl's Instagram I didn't say yeah I
say I said he's rooting for the Rams
because he's the Shawn McVeigh of the
medical field the youngest in his field
oh I don't get the reference this coach
of the Rams is the youngest head coach
ever
he's like 33 and he's in the Super Bowl
you know I think Ben would have would
have not not necessarily disagreed
because this is Ben's theory and it's
not wrong it's like obviously everyone
like the Patriots are like the coolest
they got the Jews they'll like it's easy
to root for a winning team so like Ben
was obviously in Vegas like everyone
like the odds were in the Patriots favor
so Ben obviously one of them to win for
that reason but also Ben could have saw
the Rams when it cuz they're a young
team and he wants them to go far you
know right there they're the Theos of
the they're like a new team like they
believe it around for two years they
moved yeah biggis yes seriously like I'm
trying to work here and so did Co he
packed up and left his home as well
Dallas Fort Worth know who Russia oh so
there was just so many similarities and
I had to draw the comparison I was
thinking of you and I was thinking of
theö the whole wedding weekend cuz the
theme of the weekend which I never
really realized so this is my friend
honor she and her husband have been
together for seven years she would just
go could speak what would he say let me
up on the couch I miss you guys that's
what is that what you would say is that
what you're feeling he's so dirty he's
not ready he's not camera-ready okay
she's got a really filthy shirt Brunner
of it with his paws my new shirt from
revolve Tularosa wow it really is nice I
know
check out him Sherri Bruin the shirt
well it through the show or ruin the
shirt you just saw Jackie O I mean it's
about your priorities how much did the
share cost too much too much I'm really
excited to hear what made you think of
me
and Theo precious angel men beautiful
boys gift of man all right now you sit
and relax okay so there we go hi so this
is my friend Hana my that's her honor
she and her husband have been together
since high school high school and so he
is like why was being really annoying
and you know he's off the leash he got
what he wanted I'm trying to work here
no way
okay run free man so he is Yemenite
moroccan very spartax so like for those
who don't know there's two
types of Jews here we have the Ashkenazi
Jews and the Sephardic Jews and the
astronauts use all our like he's eating
a pretzel
you know what enjoy it the of the
Ashkenazi Jews are from Eastern Europe
they're you know a porcelain skin
Holocaust vibes and that's just one type
of wash of Jim the Sephardic Jew comes
from more of like the Arabic area
Morocco Yemen Lebanon
Africa Africa so and they're they tend
to have darker skin they have a little
bit more different like traditions but
for the most part I'm forgotten Arabia
we're all world Jews but like the
spartax are a little louder you know
yeah so he is far dick Yemen and all the
people his family like all the cousins
all his friend friends and family are
Yemenite Moroccan as well Sephardic onna
is like the I never realized she's like
she is the picture of Eastern Europe
like her mom is from Germany but her
whole family's polish she has like the
whitest skin like she's so yes he's so
tan well she's ten but like I guess now
I guess compared to her like if you had
asked me before you told the story like
if she was scarred across who knows like
I might have guessed Sephardic she
little farting when we were in high
school we went to Poland for a trip and
we actually went to the shuttle that her
family's from they like really deep
roots in Poland Toma so of is what it's
called and like their game was like all
over the shuttle it was really cool
actually
and I just like for as long as I've
known her she really is just like the
face of Ashkenazi like she's very
Ashkenazi so it was really like the
merging of two different cultures and it
was so funny because like the Sephardic
side is much like louder and like every
time someone does something there was
like and so the groom's mom was telling
us like all of her friends of family
were on the same flight and they were
like so excited like screaming things in
Arabic on the plane like other people
who like more with the wedding we're
freaking out cuz like all these people
were just like screaming on a plane and
it was just really like a very
culturally inspiring wedding so what
made you think of Theo and I so Anna is
really like from the shuttle with her
borscht she pled and they played Fiddler
on the Roof as one of the songs down the
aisle
you mean Theo on the roof yeah fiddler
on the Tigs tikki on the roof
- I wasn't at that kid at the CMA Awards
and he had a fiddle
of course facing fanzi how could I
forget every run if you're new to start
maybe you cuz who came from mr. Crabb
you should check out our CMA red carpet
coverage from this year cuz it was
actually epic it really was well I'm
glad you had a good weekend we miss you
but you know we made do
it was great it was good but it wasn't
great so sometimes I'll even like
there's no plans and I feel really
guilty about leaving but like I was
replaced like yeah like this I mean I
wish [ __ ] snitch was great um both the
American and the Italian cameras came as
you saw yeah so it was it was
conflicting for her but I think she
handled it like the consummate counselor
that she is I'm sorry
counsel you're dismissed buongiorno
maestro what's so funny is have you seen
The Godfather Godfather one do you know
console Yoda is a position yes tom she
used to be Don snitch Leone after I saw
that movie yeah and now she's council
yatta so she's been demoted
she's been demoted but I think she's
better suited for this role you know she
was but she bit off more than she could
chew that's the thing about biting I'd
love to do it so that was really fun and
then she earned a new hat on the show
I'm sure you saw I did I did the revolve
girl no yeah yeah yeah we distract and
I'm never bringing everyone i BS itchy
butt syndrome then made up that name for
the disease you don't know that no I'm
gonna ben says IBS like obviously IBS is
the actual like illness where you like
have diarrhea but Theo has IBS itchy
butt syndrome he's always scratching his
butt against the carpet and bed gave it
a name IBS I can't let you know that I
mean he must have heard him uh say it
we'd say it all the time I never am with
been with like Thea okay
I'm saying is it sounds vaguely familiar
oh and then yesterday was you know just
Bravo tastic yeah tell me about Aaron
did she spill any good and Andy of the
baby is that one of the stories of
course it is yeah here's what she said
there was some fighting going on between
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills and
Annie was like like stop one because
like you're missing me and to say before
the reunion yeah um there was some
fighting going on between New York and
New Jersey
ooh oh just across the pond well I think
charissa has said that heard Bethenny
they don't get along wasn't there
Oh mom the LVP of it all like Darren was
like downplaying shadiness but it's
definitely shaped like of course there
was still no legitimate reason as to why
she wasn't there and oh why wasn't a
pumper sir
oh but I think what it goes back to is
this all started during Okoboji faithful
when he made his announcement the OGIS
were on and that's when they decided to
plan a baby shower Lisa wasn't on that
because she only goes on watch what
happens live i/o so because you know
pride goeth before the fall
Wow included in the discussions blown us
up freeze again and want to use it pride
goeth before the fall can I tell you
something incredibly embarrassing yeah
always
okay so in the airport yesterday Ben
looked at his watch or something and he
was like it's 1106 whatever and I lost
my phone I'm like actually it's 1103
it's Michael your clock was broken
hahaha and I'm like a broken clock is
Right twice a day and then I was
perplexed for like hardcore 20 minutes
about that phrase I'm like if the clock
is always 10 minutes ahead it's never
gonna be right and me and dad were like
dumbfounded for like 20 minutes like
it's not gonna ever be right oh and then
I was like wait we're talking about
broken clock that's not fast or slow
clock and so I felt really stupid and
like that did - oh my god that's bad I
know that's that is embarrassing it was
dumb I know Wow I felt incredibly stupid
but like I figured it out and then I
joke sweating Tibetan like he's so
diverse and Wow Wow and that's where but
then it begs the question wonder why
Theo's not the brightest tool in the
shed and then it begs the question do
you consider a clock that's like running
20 minutes fast broken no it's a working
clock your he just said it wrong okay
fine that's what I said - yeah okay um
precious man how are you doing Jackie I
know it's so does your easily distracted
you look Theo
I haven't seen him in so long but people
you want to take him for a nice
run-of-the-mill shuttle hang out after
this honestly no because he stinks and I
think that's fair yeah he does it's the
worst it's ever been and excuse me my
throat really hurts okay so I think I
think that without further ado I am
ready for the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of the morning toast when I
did the podcast with Zack on Thursday I
crunch I'm by myself and it was
perfection let me hear it 3 2 1
wow it sounded just like the machine
when I did it
let me try 3 2 1
we need these man I thought was that
good yeah cuz it's yeah I think it
sounds different to you than it does
yeah because when I heard it on the
package I was like great and you were
shook ok and she danced too yeah so
anyways just interesting factoid that I
thought you might find well interesting
that's the thing about interesting
factoids there more often than not very
interesting ok first story Andy Cohen
welcomes baby boy be a surrogate Andy
Cohen is now a daddy for real on Monday
the Bravo honcho welcomed his first
child son Benjamin Alan Cohen via
surrogate Wow this is my son Benjamin
Alan Cohen he is 9 pounds 2 ounces big
boy 20 inches born at 6:35 p.m. Pacific
time he is named after my grandfather
Ben Alan I've been loved and speechless
and eternally grateful to an incredible
surrogate and I'm a dad
Wow I really like got so emotional and
like I left a weird comment on it and
I'm like I guess this I think that's
like how people feel about the chose his
way I feel about Andy like I feel like I
know him you know yeah until his baby
like I'm easy easier baby I'm I'm an
aunt now now you know how it feels
yeah I just felt really happy for him I
think the name is by the way first while
Benjamin Alan Cohen it's just like rich
first of all second of all I love that
he named after his grandfather I love
when people I was actually talking about
this over the weekend like names that we
like you know and I don't want to like
Shayla no you don't want to Shayla it
well actually my friend Margo fish-like
wouldn't tell me her name good but
actually she did actually no she didn't
she didn't it was actually that kind of
mean like yeah Mike you don't trust me I
mean what if you loved that name Simon
like that's my [ __ ] baby name
well so here's the thing I would lose a
friend over a baby name I mean Charlotte
it I really just want to put it on the
universe in terms of our sisters it's
just I feel like it's whoever comes
first they get gets it but like I like
the name Michael
yeah but like does everyone those are
dad's name um I think you could have it
will it'll depend on who I'm sure
whoever has the first son like has
has to take it is also like a lot of
pressure but I didn't plan on naming
anyone Michael oh I see I did that's
what maybe if I but I've been I didn't
vocalize it to my sisters so then it's
like Olivia Paulson and she's like
Michael and I never said anything I
couldn't be angry you know no so you
just have to get pop in like what do you
think Bolivia listen to this episode of
the toaster you think I should call her
after this I think you should call her
I think I'll just write it in the chat I
kind of feel like she's like the one
who's gonna have a baby first effort
like everyone thought it was me well
show together anyone thought it with you
oh really
yeah she got her [ __ ] together so
quickly that like she's totally like
pregnant she will probably go first
hopefully go first and should go first
and that's what I want meet you because
then that because if I still got do is
like I get to enjoy all the benefits
about any of the responsibilities and
that's really what I want in terms of a
baby I don't think I can have an actual
baby until I have a niece or nephew
first cuz like I want to feel the love
and then like take the responsibility
and honestly like yes you're a mom to
Theo but you don't know what it seemed
like to be an aunt
oh okay what's it like it's just it's
it's a challenge always you're just
always fighting for time I feel like a
bachelor i watch The Bachelor literally
finishing The Bachelor is what it used
to be like in high school like finishing
your homework a hundred percent and you
know what I did last night because I was
so delayed because we were facetiming
just having of the longest face time and
I was happy and then I'm like you just
said my time back for bed 30 minutes I
know but because of the delay
I watched Vanderpump rules first and by
the way it's the move because you're
able to enjoy it more still I then I
finished about her and then I still
watch the Cinderella story like I still
had time you so but the way you just
said delay reminded me that when I
landed at the airport in Cancun there
was a sign for someone named art that
delay no yes that's funny I meant to
take a picture but then I saw like the
margarita frozen Sam and I got one and
said I'm sure it was like maybe it was
Scott or maybe it was Chris or maybe was
one of your friends just being funny
yeah no neither my friends aren't that
creative that's you mean it was for you
totally and then you know I couldn't
find my car let me mention it oh we were
talking about your boobs we'll get into
that I wanted to say one thing about a
knee and maybe I'm so happy there's
nothing more to say other than just
hearing what I'm sayin room
from my heart absolutely this shouldn't
be a story cuz like all I can say is
like a big smile so he's still in our
life people were confused I think he
must have pre-taped that okay that's
what I want to talk about because the
baby was born at 6:35 p.m. Pacific time
watch what happens live in LA in LA if
it's live if it was sight if it could
have been pre-recorded earlier in the
day but still like you just had a baby I
don't think was running back to work but
why don't you tell us that it's
pre-recorded they always do that then
another clue when Darren was here she
was talking about James and she was like
even when he came on watch what happens
live he was like we were like she wanted
drinking he was like yeah and we were
like you do know he drink I was like yes
tree but that would have meant that it
was writing before yesterday and while
she was in LA heard yeah I mean it
definitely was filmed earlier for a
million reasons play it off like it was
live but they always do that for two
reasons one the show is called watch
repens live second of all if people know
it's pre-recorded they're not gonna like
tweeting questions and call and like all
the buzz around every episode which I
call in all the time I never got through
it but I also tweak questions like I
want my through my [ __ ] read but if I
knew that it was pre-recorded and
there's literally no chance of my tweet
getting on I'm not gonna do it you know
for sure I think that's better though
than like people feeling like stupid and
now everyone's talking about it like was
it live or not like also you did have
some some third string cast members on
so it didn't make we would have not
everyone was clamoring to get on the
phone with Raquel right that she was on
who's Raquel James and Billy Lee it was
live and Andy was literally like what
the [ __ ] am i doing since this morning I
was scrolling Twitter and Kristin Jodie
was like Billy Lee James and Kristen are
not invited to Jackson Brittany's
wedding did they say anything about
Jackson regimes and Raquel said that
they were excited when Andy asked if
they believed that Jack see change in
the relationship was good they were like
honestly yeah we're really happy for
them and we're excited for their wedding
oh that's nice but the Kristen said they
won't be invited
I'm sure changed invite because Raquel
said that and James was like I agree yes
okay it was a really strange episode um
I think Andy was like honestly I need a
raise after this episode like he's
better than talking I'm sorry to Raquel
and then I was looking at the because
they seceded let me guess
James Rock Oh Billy Billy Rock cap Billy
James Orko and I was looking at the
because I was still thinking about like
the Billy Lee fight and
you know girls night in of it all and
like how much of a cast member is she
and then I was looking at the big
picture that goes in between every scene
of the whole cast and she is on the end
further away than Adam so it's like um
you know I'm the cast yeah yeah like of
the in the restaurant yes so you know
how on the fringes are really the fringe
matters yes Adam is before her so if
they had had a boys night in at Sur from
what Adam had even been on it no no
interesting interesting but they really
do include like truly everyone is
Natalie and here mom here mo in that
picture I think so they used to be M
yeah that picture is not a reflection of
like anything you know no I think that
it is it's a reflection of like who gets
a cat a check cash it so much like all
the people who were in town that could
have been on watch I was I've left and
they were left with the people who
actually live there yeah we're like they
filmed it at 4 a.m. and who's you know
what spurred enough to come yeah yeah
anyways he's a really weird episode um
and I don't think Andy was feeling any
of them I'm just like annoyed cuz like
Billy just started drama for the sake of
getting like a little bit more attention
on the show and like it worked she got
on watch happens live and that shouldn't
be allowed you know yes but I think it
backfired
oh really yeah I think she was
uncomfortable I'm watching happens live
because I think she was expecting like
more love from Andy more attention and
Andy like wasn't feeling well and he
doesn't like people taking advantage of
the platform he gives people oh my god
it was so funny Raquel and James for
defending their relationship and Andy
was like why would these people say like
that they slept with you and then watch
on eat up he's right and James will say
they want their 15 minutes they're on
Vanderpump rules baby best show on
television I think it's like he can't go
you sure about that because yet oh my
god that's so funny James actually was
making me laugh and well he was me funny
in Episode two when they put him in the
closet to DJ I couldn't stop laughing
when Annie was making find out he's like
what were you doing with your hands he
was like James was like those are my DJ
moves I've got about ten and Andy was
like you another he was doing all of
them jeez this one he was just being so
funny so self-aware and like there was
nothing mean at Andy
say that he wouldn't just turn right
back around right and I have respect for
someone like that I know oh my god me
too but I wish he could translate that a
little bit more on the show James I
really think has multiple personality
disorder cuz sometimes don't see him in
an interview or like just random moments
on the show and I'm like wow he really
is like this self-aware like normal
person then he says and does like evil
terrible things where I'm like oh no
you're a psycho yeah speaking of people
from Bravo we have Jennifer and Jackie
tomorrow from real houses in New Jersey
on the show and I truly can't wait I'm
actually really surprised they're doing
press together I guess obviously because
they're like branded as the new girls
but they don't seem like the best of
friends and I want to just like talk to
them I'm really excited and then next
week we have Melissa Gorga I'm so
excited to meet Jennifer we've already
met Jackie and I love Jennifer got me
met Jackie at age six yeah I I love
Jennifer monkeys [ __ ] they do [ __ ]
suck no I think every ever since that
episode aired I've said that on the show
every single day you know what
you know how much up in zyv they have
like the you're such a [ __ ] liar
Camille button where like it just says
we need that that you [ __ ] suck
anytime someone says something mean to
me like oh you look ugly today ugly
today I think you [ __ ] something like
the monkeys [ __ ] then you [ __ ]
soft she's somebody in the way she said
it with her Jersey accent I love her
like I can't just like a while I can't
move just like the phonetics of it I'm
having a heart in grayned in my mind not
jumping into the van okay
yes right and he had a baby
congratulations much congratulations
next story Kylie Jenner is on the cover
of architect Architectural Digest
flaunting her $500,000 purse collection
I'm gonna venture to guess that it's
worth more we have a photo for you
course on the stream it is so [ __ ]
beautiful
I could stare and zoom in on it all day
and I want the rest of the closet as
well for some reason the Kardashians
like respect the [ __ ] out of
Architectural Digest like Courtney's
obsessed with it I mean it's a
respectful magazine obviously but like
they care about it as much as like they
care about vogue no totally and you know
what as well they should like Vogue is
out architectural Massey black vogue out
Architectural Digest in precious angel
man in always this may look like a
luxury boutique but it's actually Kylie
Jenner's over-the-top purse closet which
she uses to hold her massive handbag
collection the 21 year old beauty mogul
flaunts her fairytale custom closet in
the March star power issue of
Architectural Digest
an entire row is dedicated to
highly-coveted Hermes Birkin bags with
with at least 10 of the sought-after
celebrity favorite Birkins the bags made
of ostrich and other animal skins can
range in price from ten thousand to over
two hundred thousand dollars the total
collection visible in the photo appears
to be worth at least five hundred
thousand dollars the bottom row alone
with seven bags on a white lacquer shelf
including Fendi Louboutins supreme X
Louie Vuitton is worth at least forty
thousand dollars yeah that supreme Louie
Vuitton cabal is worth at least $10,000
and do they take in the value of what it
took to build this closet because with
the mirrors the lights the shelves that
is easily like a million-dollar closet I
don't know if they did and that
automatically ups the value of whatever
price check they're putting on this
thing
okay so I just want to go through this
closet like I want to vomit I'm green
with envy why do I know it's really like
and it by the way it's organized so
perfectly like big totes on bottom this
is my dream and like she just has such
great taste in some of these bags are
like uh years old they're not vintage
yet though but it's like just a
collection actually like the movie tonk
graffiti I love she has um the
Louboutins very literally having an
orgasm no I'm dead she has the mama
flash which is my [ __ ] favorite bag
she has the Masters no wait
no she doesn't I'm sorry I think that's
virtual the iridescent I believe Louie
Vuitton oh yes she has a few feet what
are we not even seeing she's
representing Virgil she loves the
supreme collection I mean who doesn't
she loves a good Gucci Dionysius could
you bag that you buy a Gucci bag Gucci
bag what do you think max eleven surance
policy is her insurance policy I don't
know it's like I literally every time I
buy somebody new I call in Geico and I'm
like and share this [ __ ] you know look
at this ermes it's like a Sherpa Emily's
car carrier music rock music yeah look
at this blue velvet ermes you guys know
that's [ __ ] dead for scenes this is
my new 11:11 wish Kylie's closet Kylie's
closet Kylie okay I just want to say
like why is this an architectural digest
that's the thing her whole house is
sorry yeah that's an perfectly love I
know her glam room is so cute and then
also chris is on the cover a different
cover just move because it's the star
power issue so there's a couple
different cult oh I picked me up a copy
no finally architectural drive just like
Architectural Digest it's really hard to
say first of all no it finally got the
inside scoop of the do bromance
they built and they got the worst
[ __ ] pictures you saw like literally
three rooms not he was a confident
because she saved that for her [ __ ]
YouTube channel my dish is Mesa thirteen
I don't know she is let you have a man
chance you have a man chin and like you
turned down a role on the Real
Housewives of Orange County like that
does not a thirst monster make no and
like I don't know there's something
about happy having a mansion and a
YouTube channel that just like clash
yeah even though sometimes the key to a
mansion it's just a youtube channel it's
true
but Kelly Kelly it's a working first to
check another welcome first the mansion
or the YouTube channel and for Heather
Dubrow it was a mansion so she does
therefore she doesn't in the YouTube
channel yeah I didn't like all the like
cool youtubers like what like what's her
name what's her name
Carli bybel like the big beauty bugger
like she totally has a mansion I watched
her I'm home tour but the YouTube
channel came first you know yes
sometimes a YouTube time convenient
mansion hence why we're here yeah we are
out here every day putting another brick
into the water of our mansion but we
need to that's annoying
unless dual mansions we live together
but separate it's like a two family
house and we co-parent the tig I'm gonna
be epic
that would be really cool if we had like
a I guess it's called like an estate we
had multiple homes so each team could
have their own home I mean that's a my
drink yet my dream is actually just like
living in the same apartment building
like a small building that has like 10
or 15 units and we own about five of
them beautiful yeah okay we'll work on
in I mean here we are working on it okay
let's do a better job on the show today
um a bunch of the comments are
requesting that we jingle or shoes for
them I don't understand
oh okay I guess our our feet are like
right cut off I need to clean mine
because I wear them in the rain so now I
have spots on them I like your shoes are
they lucky
silver Gucci shoes good shoes good shoes
good shoes Gucci shoes do you know my
birthday is coming up so I guess I
should request something since eleven
eleven it's just where we make things
happen like your Gucci bag was made it
happen so I'm gonna say um blue diamond
scarf so no one can get something else I
do know that that is what I'm getting
for Valentine's Day because I love him
then a photo of it I'm gonna say I feel
seriously you were so good take a [ __ ]
nap and relax
go to sleep annex go to sleep I'm gonna
say Louboutin iridescent whoa yeah well
800s at little fatahna or doesn't
louboutin or doesn't little Tamera
Desson well you know you know what
happens my mind the collection has been
so shamed by critics maybe it'll go on
sale soon but I change my mind
Froyo machine Fredo Machine Freddie
machine that's really I want I will know
that I've made it now I refer your
machine in my house maybe he just needs
a little TLC precious Tigs love and care
precious boys mad so can you make that
up anything for your machine or a
Louboutin bag I'll look into it but
didn't have to get all the ingredients
you gotta keep out or a fountain soda
machine oh that's like I run a popcorn
machine
I think I might move what yeah because
my apartment is just now so cluttered
and I think that it's only cluttered
though because if you register I know
but I think that instead of trying to
put everything away we don't even have
space for everything uh we should move I
think your time I think the apartment
was never even meant for Tomatoes we're
into a temporary it was meant you know
to like just save us
mhm um but I'm kind of in looking on
street easy oh my god I'll totally go
with you and like looking at places
because you did find my apartment for me
I did a lot I found it but you went and
looked for it for me I guess I was in
error they confirmed that she just had
to move there that it was just the best
place for Theo to be raised yeah
precious man what are you trying to say
that he loved here and me check if the
oppa talk what would he say that he
loves his hands meet Russ and he's just
so excited to be a part of this a small
part of the greatest morning show on
earth and the community that comes with
it I'm it's so many toasters by the way
implies I Carmen you did yeah he went to
sur ok did they go there yes ok so I was
walking back in my friend microfiche she
was like a Bravo his story and she
actually like knows more I would say
than you she's not she was going back
and rewatching like almost every
franchise she's watching Atlanta yeah
precious gift he's getting what he wants
which is a warm hug from Mom's me chest
and to sit next to and Sneetches who
loves him so much so like a cancer we
were walking by and Margo was like I
swear they went there and been if I
world like did they mmm-hmm sir
steakhouse
they weren't laughing Sue's Mexican sir
it was so funny I wanted to head but
like everyone was dragging me on I went
to catch in Playa del Carmen it was
actually very very cool I was the breeze
by the ocean
you couldn't put a price on that you
know I would have paid $10,000 for the
dinner alone just because of the breeze
for the breezy vibe yeah even though I
didn't even end up paying for dinner
someone else said whoo it was such a big
group dinner like someone's paid for it
now nobody asked me for anything I think
I might have thrown some cash at someone
but it's unclear damn I need friends
like that okay anyways let's pick up a
copy of Architectural Digest it's hard
to say of a ad say Architectural Digest
five times fast
Architectural Digest Architectural
Digest Architectural Digest
Architectural Digest structural digest
not just oh you did it
you do it okay well also wrangling my
son hi my precious gem Architectural
Digest Architectural Digest
Architectural Digest Architectural
Digest Architectural Digest
oh we just licked my face that's my guys
breath that was scary okay now we have
three business news stories three guys
well not business that's what I just
call anything I cannot celebrity news we
need a better scale that means I look
like business you need a better word for
it how about just news okay three news
stories but how about this the boy
boring stories yes for Millennials
cancers fueled by obesity are on the
rise
study says well this is pertinent
because we are Millennials and we are
obese Oh cancers filled by obesity are
on the rise among young adults in the
United States and appearing at
increasingly younger ages according to
an analysis released Monday by the
American Cancer Society the study
published in The Lancet Public Health
examined data on twelve obesity obesity
related cancers between 1995 and 2014
waiting room we went to CMA fest at no
CMA Awards and we had to walk through
the Music City Center and at the Music
City Center it also happened to be
obesity week yes and we were like oh
we're totally in the right place yes as
well as 18 common cancers not a Saudi
and not associated with weight they
found a disturbing trend among adults
aged 24 to 249
quote the risk of cancer is increasing
in young adults for half of the obesity
related cancers with the increased
steeper in progressively younger ages
said co-author of Madine Jamal who is
the vice president of the surveillance
and Health Services Research Program for
the American Cancer Society if you had
told me this story six months ago like I
would have had a pic because I actually
like was borderline obese now I'm just
like healthily chubby and you know you
were borderline obese
the cure for cancer hadn't been almost
ready oh right guys eat away install has
cured cancer Israel in a year we will
have you know drug said and then there
were some people who were questioning
the validity the validity of the claims
and I don't I'm not questioning the
validity of the claims however what it
seems to be is that it's not necessarily
a cure for cancer but more so you know a
cocktail of drugs that will make cancer
along our death sentence but something
that you can live with but you know just
taking medicine yes I think it's like
people compare it to like AIDS yes you
can
I think live with AIDS if you're on the
proper cocktail yes
also never and this is the thing about
cancer is like people are always putting
out just like research papers and that's
like at the thing in in friends Ross is
a paleontologist and he's always like
writing articles and he says in one
episode like they all get like ripped
apart like brutally rebuffed and it's
like people are just always writing
articles with like no [ __ ] claims you
know yeah but it's like actually I do
think like out of all the things in the
world like being overweight like it's
really bad for you
you know like health-wise like I issued
when I was actually chubby like a you
should avoid going to the doctor because
she's to tell me like all the things
like that my weight was doing to me like
my cholesterol blood pressure and like
it's just hard because like when you
love to eat so much but like your
cholesterol is like really dangerously
high I think I still actually have high
cholesterol needy Cheerios you should go
to the doctor now like me I'm like not
embarrassed yeah now I'm like cuz now I
think I'm at the weight I truly was like
in eighth grade no like the twelfth
grade no it's cause like you thought you
were chubby in the 8th grade but if you
look back on pictures you just had a bad
haircut do you do you go to the
pediatrician I do still when I do you
know visit the doctor meet you it's been
a while I know and I've been going to
the like other doctors now I've just
been like going to the doctor in ob/gyn
and dentist that's about it ok
yeah and I kind of want to go to a
headache doctor but I think I should
just go to the pediatrician first and
have her tell me like then there's a
good headlight doctor
I might just have low iron also we got
to talk about something cause for
celebration because guess what who has
two thumbs and just got health insurance
you I don't think that's how long it
took since your wedding yeah
oh no sorry you tweet he'll been turned
26 yes okay but they're not a premium
health care with this parent city like
wouldn't leave for me it's like I'm like
then I need health care I'm like your
job gives it to you is like no I got the
best health care with my parents but
been turned 26 so he was forced and now
starting January 1st
I'm officially insured that's exciting
you know what if you see me on the
street an you want to punch me do it and
now you wanna that's really exciting I
look forward to it I mean a few more
weeks until I'm married in the short so
yeah so now I've just been like holding
off on all the things I need to get
classes and Ben got me vision cover
while I was holding off on all the
things but then I was like I have to go
to the [ __ ] doctor and I'll just pay
out of pocket I think it's time for a
pap yeah even though like I just hate
them that big rod they put up your
machine hurts so bad but I can't and she
said I'm just scraping I'm like I could
feel that yes I know it was bad as I
didn't you're hyping it up too much it's
like are you kidding me like two minutes
I'll never forget my first cop and now I
know why you don't get a PAP until after
you're a virgin
yeah because that's invasive stuff no it
literally breaks your hymen if it's not
already broken paps are the worst
they're not as not as as you're making
out to because I just know it's a big
clamp here and then once the Hin oh you
know I went to UM the hospital because
Ben's best friend Teddy had a baby and
it was just so special like I was in the
maternity unit and like sometimes going
to hospitals can be like really it's
like sad and depressing but this unit
was just like how the happy unit all the
nurses were just like so sweet there was
like a breastfeeding class that Eileen
went to like as we got there they like
had all the new moms like give him a
class it was just like that's where I
want to be and then I'm like I'm like
Ben let's do it well you must have
brought back memories of when you picked
up the O in the maternity yeah I do and
I'm with the old crawled out of my
vision he was just like hey mom dude my
mom oh we have a Theo cam [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] premium this show just gets
better and better also to tell you
something so funny about how the toast
is just really like impacting lives
taking over the world how people are
giving us [ __ ] about going to the
pediatrician okay
buzz off and our pediatrician has said
that we can continue to go to her until
we have children of our own so when she
can treat those children but you can't
treat us right so I just want to
reiterate
buzz off oh my god honestly like beep
like Buzz Lightyear if you guys if you
would have said like there's one thing
you said on the show if you would have
said Claudia there's one thing you said
on today's show that
people are upset about like honestly I
could have picked 10 other things I
thought it was gonna be like I didn't I
didn't know if is you know mine was it
I don't want to draw attention to
something I said ten minutes ago no
totally and it's like it's always how it
is like when we did our podcasts about
just our diets we were just answering
questions toasts McGavin I did want to
say something about the impact of the
toast the power of the chose because I
met some tweezers in Peyer Dale Cardwell
yes I met some toasters in Playa del
Carmen but my friend Margo who had
flurry spoke about on the show 100 times
today
he's a toaster and at the wedding like
every like every 30 minutes I would run
back to my table put on deodorant and
spray send bird perfume on me and I
carry like three of like the little mini
travel size portions and Margo French
comes up to me she goes in September and
I'm like yes my girl how do you know
that's a bird she said the toast she's
Co toast she chose a subscribers plugged
in yeah but really like ibis prey so
much for a few Mon I got home honest and
I still smelled like perfume but the
travel size ones for the little clutches
that you bring to weddings like you
can't bring a big bottle of perfume you
can't even really bring deodorant so to
said birds I mean I've heard you most
definitely can't say San Bernardino's
partner if you're new to that shows me
because he's on my Instagram post last
night the Sanford is a monthly
subscription where they send you travel
size very small versions of like Kucha
designer perfumes you get to choose
which one you can try any ones or you
can use some of your favorites the mini
bottles get you 120 sprays which is
enough to last you a month till the next
month where you can choose new ones or
get the same I throw them really in
every single bad bag that I have every
time I walk into a meeting or anywhere
it's really like I have to say like one
of the best things that I only know
about because of the toast so if you
haven't signed up yet with an exclusive
offer for our listeners you can get 50%
off your first month that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance
go to scent bird dot-com slash toast
use code toast for 50% off your first
month that's sent
bird SC EMT BIR decom slash toast
use code toast to get your first perfume
or cologne for just seven dollars and
fifty cents you know who needs scent
hurt today
vo he needs to get [ __ ] we woke the
Beast oh you can't say his name you
can't say his name he's just his name
he's just so aware of like his
surroundings cuz he's so smart that he
knows his own name yes he really has
bucked everything his parents taught him
and turned out to be a genius can you
believe how like a lady like I look like
on the show J I'm like actually blending
him at the background and you actually
look like you you look like me I do you
wear trousers
no but I wear a lot of
that's stirlitz and I'm just like so
thin and skinned with my revolve pink
shirt I'm really 11 11 make a wish I
think brightly shining brightly shining
brightly should I say Kylie's closet
Kylie's closet justice for the girls
justice for the girls chances for the
girls justice girl go girls justice for
the boys justice for the boys justice
for the boys justice for the boys bride
singer Michael Jackson okay um no I'm
Richie Rich I don't think I took a
breath since 1110 your face you're so
red color is your hair you're lying I'm
lying I'm never in rich irradiated
McDonald's in his house that's a dream
yeah you should see if that house is for
sale
totally also like it was obviously a set
and speaking of sets that I need to
visit we've got to visit with stare
you're lying it's like a parentless I
mean you could like go see I like
Universal are one of the studios where
people are getting taken advantage of
all the time yeah I agree we should we
should hit LA yeah it's just saying that
is that glass eye I'm getting along it's
like I was like we should go to LA he
was like for our honeymoon I was like no
that is not a honeymoon no not at all
but I'm going if you wanna come when
when I have shows there I'm also like
staying for the week doing some meetings
you know yeah I love LA you do I love LA
these are the best
Bravo really picks like the most obscure
songs for their intros that's why like
because I only watch shows on Bravo when
CSI he chose an actual song from the
radio I was like shook to the core and I
loved it like every time I hear that
song I feel like I want to go to the
beach get some freckles and be in a
bikini except not the bikini part what
is I love LA from Shahs of Sunset
yeah when he was a wee run
oh yeah I don't know I think it's a
rerun you're right
yeah that's life here on sunset rich and
famous I am success but I feel like do
if you do love sex do me a favor
lose the dress we run la nice I'll say
it once I say it again Shahs of Sunset
it's a great it's most underrated show
on television actually spoke to him Jay
the other day she is like never on her
phone and then she is all at once let me
just like got to catching up I love her
so much she's on bed rest but she's fine
and her baby shower is sometime soon
that she did invite me to so we have to
go to LA oh cool we love it oh so I'm I
didn't I don't remember when I announced
the shows but I would be an Irvine and
Brea California Irvine sold-out
I think we're adding a second show Brea
and there's like 10 tickets left hit it
up that's it
else we added another Houston show that
was almost sold out South Carolina I
hate to see it happen
head to girl no job column for all your
ticket needs you ready for the next
story in our news section new section
Chloe but was a woman oh they canceled
Runyon Hawaii's considering a bill that
bans cigarette sales to anyone under 100
Wow
the legislature finds that the cigarette
is considered the deadliest artifact in
human history so begins the new text of
a new bill the text of a new bill in
Hawaii State House calling for a phased
ban on cigarettes sales in the state by
2024 Hawaii has some of the most
restrictive cigarette laws in the nation
in 2016 it became the first state
Theresia age to buy cigarettes 21 now
its new bill calls for raising the
cigarette buying age to 30 by next year
up to 40 50 and 60 in each subsequent
year and up to 100 by 2024 that would
effectively clear Hawaii stores shelves
of cigarettes although tourists could
still bring them in I'm curiously Hawaii
would offer its scent centenarians at
100 year olds the chance to buy
cigarettes near the end of their life if
they could find them so here's some
thing about cigarettes
the thing is didn't ever really know how
to feel on this issue because I don't
smoke cigarettes I absolutely hates the
smell of cigarettes and like when people
smoke around me like I want to die but
like that's your choice like you want to
like Philly a lot like that's cool like
I don't care it doesn't affect me
actually it kind of does with the
secondhand smoke but whatever it doesn't
really affect me so like I don't really
care if people aren't so
and I think it's weird like ever mean
like tells people what to do like I was
really with Mike Bloomberg all the way
until he tried to take our photos away
and like in our salt and the soda
directly affected me like I am the type
of person who would go to 7-eleven and
buy that big a size and I have many
times I do maybe once a month so like
that directly affected me and it's like
that's my choice like if I would like to
uh subsidize like get rid of doughnuts
and eat soda like that's on me do you
know what I mean
I love eating soda yeah but like like
where does you know maybe this isn't the
right show for this but like where does
the government like when they're just
trying to look out for us and where do
they step over the line I'll say I think
it's taking away your sodas
it's it taking away our cigarettes maybe
not like I think maybe it's time
cigarettes be gone but doesn't does the
Joule go next this is a jewel go necks
and here's my thing on cigarettes first
of all I'm a person who believes do
whatever you want like as long as you're
not bugging me yeah that is my policy on
life on life so when it comes to
cigarettes okay sure secondhand smoke it
doesn't like unless the only place I
feel like you really sell smell
cigarette smoke is like in New York City
because we're just like so jam-packed
close to each other yeah so I just feel
it so if people want to buy cigarettes
like let them buy cigarettes and if they
don't they don't and I also think it's
so hypocritical for who the powers that
be to like fan cigarettes and then push
the legalization of weed like I am very
mature for the legalization of weed and
the continued sale of cigarettes yeah
but I guess weed has actual medical
benefits where there's literally not one
benefit to smoke cigarettes sure but
they both also have negative traits also
if you're smoking me doesn't that it
doesn't that smoke get into your lungs
total it's the same practice it's like
clean I don't know no can call I it
doesn't have nicotine which is but it's
still like smoking your lungs now unless
you're eating it it's still yet you're
still ingesting smoke also weed is also
addictive don't come for me but it is
you know I'm here for the legalization
of weed I'm just also here for like like
people stop it telling me what to do you
know it's like that's what the laws are
and I'm feeling like they're very
constricted to someone even though like
mostly laws that are being passed like
don't apply to me like I don't smoke I
grads anyone smoke weed but like if they
did like I would care more but like I
just like I can't look like everyone
just like making up I mean oh I get that
like the law is like just like rules and
we have to follow it but like I just
really could do with like a less of them
you know maybe like we all want to be so
uptight
if it weren't so many laws right I'm
here for a lawless society and
oh god no no no I think those are good I
think it's good that you can't buy
cigarettes until you're a certain age so
I but I don't think that the
legalization of weed is the same as like
I think it's the government exerting an
amount of control on the decisions that
you make in your personal life so if
you're gonna make if it's gonna swing
one way you got to swing all the way
great cuz then it's like okay so like
you know sometimes I yell at my husband
like it's the government gonna get a
mommy for that that's not good if Ben
becomes president oh my god that's Ben's
first order of business
no yell has been wives who yell at their
husbands get ten years in jail
well I'll visit [ __ ] you'll be in jail
with me too don't lie everyone will babe
what do you mean you just would be on
Lulu season anyways this is I mean
personally I think that this is a good
move for Hawaii cuz like the country so
beautiful and when you're in Hawaii like
you shouldn't be smoking cigarettes cuz
you want to enjoy your life and not
short man but this is totally like a
part of it then it's also like style bro
it's apartment cigarettes I don't like I
feel like it's more I don't know then
it's like when you're in the cool crisp
a or like hey let's by mistake or like a
cigar already we gonna ban cigars next
yeah that's a good call but you know
what I really know very little about
this and that's my thing these days is
just speaking on things that I don't
know a lot about and that's actually got
me some really mean comments so I'm
gonna sit this one out
speaking of comments I want this is
worth noting that weed is
psychologically addictive but not
chemically addictive oh so there's
nothing in it that is making addictive a
person personality interesting that is
interesting that is because they say
people have addictive personalities and
that is definitely an interesting
factoid that's interesting and isn't
pertinent to this conversation
I think that's literally the definition
of an interesting fact that's well
interesting and pertinent to this
conversation because so so lodged
because you know does a sociology major
why didn't she tell us that she doesn't
tell us anything pertinent to this as we
have conversations about things we don't
know we like learn through the comments
and we like we get somewhere you know
yeah so where I'm getting is I'm glad
that this is happening in Hawaii cuz
it's a beautiful place and it shouldn't
be marred down by cigarette smoke um but
overall my thoughts on this are if
people are smoking cigarettes and they
want to smoke cigarettes
let them yes we can discourage it in all
these different ways and your truth
commercials are out there and they cost
a million dollars now with
all the taxes and you're discouraging
people but at the end of the day let
people do make their own decision I'm
sorry I just changed my mind on the
entire subject I have to say I'm done
with cigarettes I totally forgot I said
you don't understand as a dog mom
i watch vo and people literally throw
like half smoking cigarettes on the
floor and they don't do the shoe like
they did in Greece they don't grease it
they just leave the lip thing and Theo
just walked with his bare feet and every
time I'm like pulling him away from lit
[ __ ] cigarettes I'm sorry I take it
all back cuz now I'm affected Theo is
always like dodging half-lit and
cigarettes that people just throw on the
sidewalk they don't even they don't
stand it you know what are you just
thinking about it said none of that
what did you say uh tell me about it
yeah done no [ __ ] cigarettes Hawaii
or elsewhere interesting Wow now do we
actually need to get on that right now
they got on people throwing their gum
people who just throw their gum it
actually kills pigeons because they
think it's food to eat it and then it
closes their mouths shut and they can't
breathe yeah they got on that and now
people don't do that anymore now PETA
cigarettes thirty mark Peeta Mellark
PETA yes and then someone else I just
want to acknowledge the comments cuz
someone said that their friend has a
gluten allergy
IBS when is addicted to gluten but
smokes lot of weed to deal with the
stomachaches this year they're not
talking about medical marijuana in any
way shape or form we are talking about
recreational marijuana
yeah no medical marijuana saves lives
for sure that is where a lady Lynette
she couldn't eat during chemo we're all
of a sudden she's making brownies for
the whole neighborhood a being of food I
thought this was an exciting story for
us dieters out there except you can't
say that word anymore especially now on
the toast because I didn't know that it
was such a sensitive subject oh I do I
know you did you tried to warn us I did
and you know I guess thought you know
the dozers where we'd always can just
agree to disagree we see differently you
and I see differently on certain things
hallo top is expanding beyond pipes with
mini ice cream bars q halo table known
for making pints of low-calorie ice
cream is trying something new ice cream
bars after a few years of meteoric
growth the small company is maturing
halo top CEO Justin Wolverton told CBS
CNN business that's his niche she needs
to date the CEO of halo top
she can make something change it what's
his name Justin Wolverton over certain
wo o and see if we have any mutual
friends on Facebook which is the same ER
T oh and Justin Wilber first google him
to make sure he's you know
age-appropriate even though she loves an
older man Hugh Jackman Tim McGraw's it's
like we're ignoring all this about him
cute oh yeah really cute is he brother
in law any mutual friends but he lives
in LA hold on he does look like not
age-appropriate actually maybe he just
has a mature smile
cutie oh he went to Coachella it's not
gonna work oh yeah but you know people
can change
well we don't have any mutual friends
let's see if he follows girls no job
looks like your day on the show Darrin
has something about Coachella and I
wound up recapping our experience there
and I hadn't thought about it in such a
long time of how treacherous it was oh
my god
I think about it once a week every time
like maybe I'm a revolved girl should I
go to but you know okay I found his
Instagram he unfortunately does not
follow me he also doesn't follow
literally anyone that I know like we
have no mutual like follows you know
that's okay but maybe one of the
toasters knows him oh yeah put out does
he's single let's see if he was wearing
a ring in any of these pictures okay I'm
a nut butter he's verified ooh
it's Mitch you know he goes to a lot of
festivals okay well you know it was nice
it was good yeah Oh precious angel where
you going to do well if you know of any
CEOs who Margo can date yeah that run
like low-calorie ice cream or that like
can help further our careers like maybe
the CEO of like a media company or
something totally new products like the
ice cream pop can help the company grow
in a more sustainable way each pop
contains 50 and 60 calories the new bars
which come in packs of six are hallo
tops first nan pipe retail product they
come in strawberry shortcake YUM mint
chip peanut butter swirl and chocolate
chip cookie dough Wolverton says the
Pops are quote very snackable unlike the
pines which are made for volume eating
that is very true
well um I actually don't eat halo top
because like ice cream is the one thing
like if I'm giving up so much you know
for the sake of Michael and that I I
refused to give up ice cream especially
cuz I live in New York and the number
one ice cream even though it's going out
of business left and right is Tasti
D'Lite
and it's not
not bad for you hungry in terms of
calories it is very chemically which I
can think is good because I always get
like the worst gas afterwards but that
is the one thing I won't let go of you
don't I mean yes and I beg you of make
flurries because he delights are going
out of business I have an idea for you
you should find one that is and by
therefore your machine no oh my god I
see something else I thought of a better
idea well that's one out of business you
can and buy the franchise it's like a
failing business how much gonna be I'll
get a loan and then we'll have toast our
meetups there and then it'll be like so
[ __ ] expensive like aside from the
toaster meetups I saw if you see this
thing on my hand you podcasters can't
see it it's a big orange circle
it's from the henna from the wedding it
suppose to be good luck so if you want
to touch it like maybe like fertility
and stuff like that ooh or maybe I'll
get it vo the second oh IBS is coming
out also Hannon Bell wrote something
funny oh you see through and by the way
she writes all the funniest stuff and
are you sure it's a bell cuz it looks
like Buble spelled like Buble without
that first B you don't watch the
Superbowl but there is a commercial that
was so funny what was it it was for
bubbly that drink yes with Michael Buble
and he's trying to convince everyone
that it's pronounced Buble genius and
then they were like this mister the
store owner comes in is like I'm sorry
but it's pronounced bubbly and he goes
okay davay so funny so funny
and then he's sitting on the floor of
like the 7-eleven or wherever it is like
changing all the cans to say Buble oh my
god nobody cos we pronounce everything
like that like the to us it was really
funny she said I used to thoroughly
enjoy halo top until I fell asleep with
a bowl on the table overnight and it did
not melt and I decided it is not real
food what okay that's never happened to
me because usually actually a lot of
people love halo top because you can eat
the whole pint and it's not that bad but
I can't eat the whole pie because all
that fake sugar does give me a stomach
ache but I can eat have a pint feel like
sort of satisfied and move on no it's
definitely a good idea and I'm actually
it's like the type of brand that I like
Margo knew about it a long time ago so
I've kind of like watched its growth and
it's like really impressive and they
definitely like are in the green you
know they spend the money that they make
you know like they're a good like Corp
they have a good business they should
have went on Shark Tank but they didn't
because they didn't need it so as a
fellow business owner I'm excited for my
fellow entrepreneurs but did you know
that Margo took a career because Margo
is now like graduating and she really
needs to like find out what she wants to
do with her life and she took one of
those career
tests and you know what it said she
should be an entrepreneur
so basically unemployed it's like the
least helpful thing ever that is so
funny take one of those like your
aptitude tests I don't think so I think
we should take it see what it says yeah
but I've actually been getting asked a
lot if you're going to Harvard oh I'm
sorry
ah my life just became so busy right
around the time that I decided to go to
the Ivy League that's what happens my
glom Goblin god [ __ ] locked in my
face because I didn't have the time to
even take a gmail pac-man slams table
but also the schedule I think are you
setting your application in September so
I was just tabling it until I got
married and then and then I would figure
it out but when it's like the this test
date you know yeah there's a lot of them
like the SATs only happen once a year
right no yes but that's different gene
that's there they happen more often
because you know not everyone is on the
same school schedule and people who like
take the GMAT it's like also like
husbands wives careers and like lives
and nephew see chess is of course okay
something but enjoy it the are you ready
talking about bachelor Vanderpump rules
I mean it's literally been so hard for
me to not talk about bed up rules let's
get that sir out of the way cuz like
let's just do better for both no no no
because we were like almost done with it
but that's true he's gonna live
yeah looks like a little pizza a little
just a little cancer okay if I'm being
from girls um what happened Oh was
opening up Tom Tom and I was actually
like finally like really annoyed because
we were invited to that party it was
July 11 and I had every intention of
going but like I just couldn't make it
work and I actually when I was watching
was so [ __ ] glad that I wasn't there
because you saw those people waiting
around outside that would have been me
like not being able to get in like now
my RSVP didn't go through whatever some
[ __ ] no when in the background like of
lolloping the house is looking like a
huge [ __ ] loser yeah so I was really
happy me to go yeah and there's no a/c
oh and no toilets that was actually so
funny that was really funny I was really
sad for Kristen okay I'm so glad
everything before you say that last
night's episode was episode of being me
feeling bad for people here are the
people I felt bad for him will go into
Kristen Jax and scheana Kristen and Jax
for sure scheana let's start with will
go in okay Kristen Lisa Vanderpump is he
so mean evil everyone was like she
made that whole conversation happen just
so that she can make sure Kristin wasn't
coming there's no reason for Stasi to be
there and not Kristin they take up the
same amount of space and they have the
same relation she'll even look as if
friends and what's one more person she
wasn't even bringing Carter because by
the way it's not even about that
it's about Kristin Dodie was invited
from Daily Mail probably it's not about
her going as a friend of Tom Tom
it's her going as a reality star who was
definitely invited to the Daily Mail TV
party and here said there was a a moment
in time a few moments in time where
Kristin was a legitimate psychopath and
I personally couldn't stand her and I
was like why is this person still on the
show since then she has reformed in a
lot of ways and is not like that anymore
and what is the point of changing
apologizing and evolving if people
aren't gonna give you another chance if
if Lisa is always gonna judge her based
on the person she was four years ago
why should she even be a better person
now no but here's the thing Lisa Lisa
knows she really now has no control over
the people that the Vanderpump rules
created like her working at Sur has not
affected Kristen in any way like she
still is a famous whatever like it's
it's just
Christina's actually proof at how much
Lisa Vanderpump doesn't really matter
anymore because they've outgrown sir
they're there it's like it's all acting
there it's fake so Kristen still
maintains the same life and has the same
social life even though she doesn't work
out sir and Lisa doesn't like that
because Lisa likes to maintain control
over these people she she did she
created them so her not inviting Kristen
to that party is her just asserting the
little amount of power she has left
right but I just thought it made her
look so evil especially if you're gonna
make that rule it has to apply to
everyone so that does include Stassi
yeah even though I need it Stassi to be
there no it was scheana there I believe
everyone was there no when they had that
conversation I'm like oh okay no one's
gonna be there just just Ariana and
Katie the wives of Tom and Tom but then
everyone was getting dressed I'm like no
so basically everyone's still invited
except for Katie yeah because Peter was
working Lala was working I think scheana
might have even everyone else could say
that they were working and to estas en
Kristen were the only really friends of
Tom Tom come it was really mean like I
and she was already dressed like I can't
Lee didn't give her more notice in like
a couple hours it was really it made me
I mean Abhi's I can San Lisa I do every
way on Beverly Hills and I'm Vanderpump
Rosen like she's so mean about Jax and
Kristen and it's like she's even Jax
again someone who has changed she
continues to talk about him
and like treat him as someone from two
years ago yeah and what's the point of
changing if people don't give you
another chance when Jack is talking
about his mom I'm like I really like was
getting so upset and I think that when
like I was just feeling so bad for him
and he was talking about how his dad
used to call him every time on his
birthday and his mom used to call him
I'm in though I'm I rented the car like
it was so cute and I felt really bad for
him and I just love him like I Billy
like he's my favorite
the two of them are my favorite when
they were at Lobster and they were just
having like such a cute time and they
were like be your cheese we should have
brought it here this is a perfect type
of place for it right and like that's
not how you got your business into it
you know one reality show it is I guess
they put that place on the map server
the [ __ ] beard you guys sure but they
still need their like food license and
stuff yeah I read somewhere they don't
got to get their business off the ground
right but you know but planning a
wedding I will have their beer cheese I
really want to be invited to buddy I
mean there's literally like no chance
but like I really want to be in my bed I
but I think we spoke about this ready
look we should fly to town the weekend
that it is like that town in Kentucky
like say Dotel might do a live show and
like see if anybody walks by that would
be really funny yeah what that's like
people go to the Superbowl and like do
their show like that's our Super Bowl
yeah the way what a Super Bowl was so
boring because we weren't there yeah
even though um I did see and hear from
people who were there like it wasn't
just as late like last year like there
were so many parties like I was where
there's just not as many party there
weren't as many party seems very hard to
get around Atlanta
Kendall was there she was I can
literally took over an hour just to get
everywhere like it was so hard really
yeah because it's a city and they're
known for having that traffic it's in
Miami next year so I'm already making
plans with TPG that we're going but
Miami's gonna be horrible traffic why do
I need to get a helicopter or a bike cuz
it's just all down that one Street [ __ ]
I'm not gonna dress just to go on a bike
the hotel that I was at was so big and
they were head golf carts taking around
by they're like you can also take a bike
and my dude I'm not going in my robe all
sparkly dress on a bike I love a bike Oh
hate a bike love um okay so then the
next person I felt bad for I want to say
just for a second was scheana and I know
everyone like has things to say about
her but when she was sitting there
crying just like have like they don't
care about her feelings and they never
will I like felt really bad for her
because la Lala really explained it
perfectly
she's like you go to dinner with people
you're not friends with and you don't
stop talking about yourself and all the
things that are happening to you and
your life and it's annoying and girls
that already find you annoying it makes
it even worse and that was a perfect
like explanation of what it is that it
but it ended the day like she doesn't a
bed intention it's not like a bad person
she's just like a little annoying and
kind of thirsty and all she's ever
wanted was to be friends with these
girls who literally just [ __ ] hate
her and for a second I felt really bad
for her agree she's finally self-aware
enough in this moment to realize like
they don't like not even that she's not
even self-aware after seven years of
being on television she sits down to a
conversation with Lila and I was like
and she's alluding to the fact that
she's had said oh yeah I'm hollows like
wait what who and she's like no one's
told to you yet no one's [ __ ] talking
about
who you had sex with you know that was
cringy but I'm a big no but it's like
she heard this her whole approach is off
her own approach revenge no one's told
you that's so weird like it was really
weird everyone's talking about it it was
really weird
yes yes yes I agree but but I'm just
talking about isolated her whole thing
her really her Genesis on the show and
her whole Ark has been around her
wanting to be friends with the witches
of WeHo and then like a being so mean to
her in the beginning be like finally
letting her be a friend and like it
wasn't equal and then they were like
meet her and then she finally got the
point now Ariana's best friend's a saucy
like just that whole thing like I do
feel bad for her but she she's in able
to just like be a normal person like
without overthinking things and trying
so hard like just be like you know and I
don't know why she's not able to do that
and if she's different with them than
she is with Lalo or you or she's just
this way with Lila and Lalo sees her as
for who she is and she doesn't care you
know I love Lola I mean I love I love
her except for one thing I hate the way
she talks about private jets like it
makes me so cringy no I think she's so
every time she says something new and
funny about it
like she causes something different
every single time and I think that that
makes it like better than just being
like oh my god do you remember Justin
Ross Lee
no okay generally yeah okay so he was
like a New York socialite he was
actually the original an Adobe he used
to buy refundable first-class tickets
sit in the lounge in Delta take 1
million photos of himself on a computer
pretending to work leave and refund the
ticket he was not a lot of back in
Marty's cuz he owed them 40 grand he
literally was like a menace around town
like taking pictures everywhere I wonder
if his Instagram is still up and about
he was like the first Instagram thought
and he had like this girlfriend who like
looked like a Russian robot like it was
so crazy he was the first I'm Adele V
but like people really didn't care about
him now I just remembered that
and he's like literally run to like
Teterboro Airport taking picture in
front of an airport and run away before
police got to him like he was so crazy
like he talked like Lala talks about
private jets the way I imagine Justin
Ross Lee what I talked about private job
no she has to stop but like I don't know
I kind of like and also like she really
is taking all these [ __ ] so I'm glad
she's talking about it as opposed to not
talking well that's true I'm like she's
like bringing the girls oh my god when
she was like I really want to go here
but you know what idea they don't like
to drive it was two hours that was so
fun let's talk about Vegas it's like a
four-hour drive from LA
yeah that was really funny like what did
she do before she might render like and
she had to drive I'm Chucky I'm sure
she's fine with driving she just like
wanted to take the private jet obviously
who wouldn't but I'm glad like she
spreads the wealth shares with the girls
and like she's really elevated the show
so yeah as much as she needs to talk
about it go ahead like I'm just glad
that these kids who like you know their
microwave doesn't work at the same time
as their air conditioning yeah are also
fine private that's just that the
interesting thing about Vanderpump rules
which has really come to a head this
season is just like the the confusion
around their finances like when Tom and
Ariana were driving last night a million
stories are really nice Mercedes
yeah and they live in an apartment that
like literally has the same couches when
him across the news no they can't turn
the keys outlets well they're my grave
and it just the whole thing doesn't make
any sense to me no cuz they're making
big from the show but all the extra
curricular activities on Instagram
podcast as well but then it's like
Stassi has a nice apartment like she
lives yeah but it's so small amongst her
means yeah but she's like clean and
she's one person you know yeah and she
is the most recent one to move her
apartment is the newest except Britney
they have an they of a cute apartment
it's two floors
yes it's just cluttered I'm Sheena
Sheena just machine is where I'm it's
nice but it's far Tom and Katie need to
move yes they're like me it's like they
don't have enough space everything and
they can't clean up so they should move
I just want to any of them are ever
gonna get a house Tom and Ariana just
bought a house is what people are saying
they did yeah that's been their um their
plan for a while was to not move out of
this apartment so that they saved money
today okay that makes sense yeah oh I'm
so excited I wonder when we're going to
see that on this show oh my god that's
gonna be like a whole thing the
fixer-upper for sure Lisa's gonna send
her guy I would say something
controversial I don't like the Tom Tom
sign it's too small yeah and it looks
like TT and then
night only the tea's light up yeah I
don't like it cool that they have their
names like on yeah Hollywood Boulevard
Lee wherever they are I can deal with
the new sign yeah I agree I didn't like
like the branding it was a little too
like Lego world a little too Geary yeah
very gear he's very broken clock bells
dad always playing with gadgets gizmos
and gears yeah
Reese yeah I think the concept was by
Maurice yes BM um no it was him it was a
mediocre episode yeah James crying about
girl sign-in oh that was so funny how he
ripped up the letter because Raquel is
like I don't want you to send it okay
Raquel I'm votin girls night
I appreciate that he pointed out the
hypocrisy in that a green it was
extremely awkward and really funny and
Tom Schwartz is just there like hey guys
Tom Schwartz is like I don't know yeah
Alito all over the place I know but I
really like him me too I love him and
he's always sees true to who he is like
it's just who he is to not hate someone
who called his wife that but what's so
crazy and I think you pointed this out
to me is like he got his own restaurant
and he never worked at Sur like they
said only rewards people who are good to
her and obey her like she rewards Katie
in space maybe that's why Katie's been
so guitar she came TVs husband a
restaurant yeah but it's Katie's husband
I feel like the girls are everyone else
is like a little jell oh my god of
course and it also just like it's only
cuz his name is Tom that he got the
restaurant you know like remember he had
a panic attack as a one time he worked
at pump and never went back
yes well they could she could have made
like a witches of WeHo astronomers yeah
I wanted to but like if he's rewarding
she should it should have been Jackson
Thompson balls restaurant they worked at
they still both are the only ones work
at Sur yeah we just
Tom Sanibel technically not work at Sur
anymore oh I don't know he still does
right now he's still behind the bar
remember Oh some one of the testers went
and saw him yeah yeah anyways
bachelor so boring so boring the island
is beautiful but it's obvious like the
moment we've been waiting for is Colton
jumping over the thing okay so I never
look at Twitter and I went to look at
Twitter last night just to see if I'm on
the right side of the fights whatever
and everyone is like so obsessed with
this fence thing they're like when they
get to Thailand start the Google map see
where the fences are yeah is so [ __ ]
everyone's waiting for the fence episode
like Colton walk storm thing me fans
yeah I think the fences next week he
gets so fed up with Nicole and uh nica's
fight that he just
and if that's really what I've been
waiting for I'll be incredibly [ __ ]
you need to he needs to send both of
them home right here right yeah because
they're they're automatic and he has no
connection with either of them you know
it doesn't matter like at this point
it's like it's no it's not worth getting
down to the bottom of it because if the
bottom is not gonna create feelings no
you know and also why is it taking
energy so long to get a one-on-one okay
I I was obsessed with energy I'm I mean
I'm still obsessed with her but I don't
think she makes it very much longer
no because the cracks in a relationship
are starting to show that they don't
have that much to talk about but that's
because they haven't gotten a one-on-one
in like why is she gonna you know give
him everything like why hasn't he demand
one-on-one from her this I think this is
the longest we've ever gone with the
first impression person not getting the
rose I think the last time it's happened
this long and I think was actually
shorter was Britt on Crystal's season
and she lost her mind as well yeah no
and I just don't understand like the way
that they picked like I wouldn't have
pegged the first the never been kissed
girl to have had such a strong
connection that she needed a one-on-one
yet you know yeah but I really like her
she is just so positive it shiny is
skinny girl I ever saw in my life
yeah like I literally was she was
walking around I'm like I'm afraid like
you're gonna break you know she says can
I just love it she wears clothes like
meant for only skinny people like she
really embraces skinniness skinny so she
had the first one-on-one right yes they
like they've done this day now 500 times
where they just like go to a market no
they like take a boat out and they just
keep landing different places yeah like
maybe that's what Highline it it's just
not fair like what's-her-face got the
best date Cassie and she's like how can
they compete of course
everyone they were painting their date
to be like the most amazing thing of
course they want to find a private
island she was in this little market
eating crickets no and also there was
nothing else for them to do like I would
have been like are we gonna eat like I
was in the cries it wasn't even like a
lounge chair no like all they could do
was swimming hiss yeah and they're like
when called Kathy was like literally
like we were just like so like physical
like of course there's literally nothing
else for you to do no totally are we
supposed to be surprised what else would
you be doing so the first day was cute
obviously a little raft in the water it
was really awkward before the fireworks
like I thought they were trying to make
it a moment of being like oh it's gonna
be an awkward first kiss no it was an
awkward thing because everybody for the
fireworks go off yeah and why I didn't
think overlay some music or something I
think they wanted us to sense the
awkwardness it really felt like a first
kiss yeah and then then they made it a
magical one once the kiss happen but
there were so many
times I think they really wanted us to
get the awkwardness that's why they
didn't put music on and I and I felt it
thank you yes
also that date like it couldn't have
been for me because when the fireworks
went off in my room I literally was like
oh and in person like I'm so easily
scared if I get into an elevator and
there someone else in there a little
scream at the top of my lungs like I'm
an embarrassment if that would even be
able to scream so hard like I would have
had to let her go to the hospital yeah
you can't just like shoot things off no
and if you don't know that they're
coming in a tee or fireworks so they're
so loud right now in this climate like
you can't just I can make a sound I mean
when we're at the Super Bowl last year
and this cannons went off kidneys climb
in yeah cannons you need to climb it
no no idea but it was cute obviously
she's no winner to me but she's a nice
girl she's great bachelor in town as
materi I'm so excited for her matter I'm
paradise she's just gonna like look
really cute and just be positive yeah I
was like she was born positive because
she is physically positive with her
dimples you know yeah and then it was
the group date where they did that
wilderness thing and those girls who
went to get burgers that was so funny
and that's when Hanabi won me back know
how dumb he got lucky being on that team
that was all about me yeah all the time
and I [ __ ] love get me true that was
so funny and even though they didn't win
by three I didn't know you could smash a
tree and whatever come out those mean
new every day yeah Teesha love her yeah
I appreciate her being manipulated and
sending the girls away so she could make
out with Colton yeah and also it was two
girls who you know are being very slow
even though uh the girl from Miami
Nicole man the other girl I can't
remember her name as she was the one
who'd Colton had to leave last night to
go buffered the fight and she's so
pretty and she was wearing my god are
sleep she's no get enough air time oh my
god she's so gorgeous they they they
filmed her getting ready for a rose
ceremony and I think she was wearing
like
vixen Mike Kylie like a dark lip it was
it it was a mood yeah and I was just
like who is she
yeah and she gets in no time but she's
like easily one of the prettiest most
normal girls there right that's probably
why she had some time yeah what happened
to Karen is chin I don't know why did
they tell us what was that I don't know
you can't just do bizarre fallen or
something like you can't just do that
look we need answers or take the
band-aid off like let's see what's
underneath no just a dress in like um I
actually was like when he was giving out
the group Rose I literally had no idea
who was gonna go to but then it was like
there was so much going on the only
person he had somewhat of a normal
conversation with was had to be so he
had Kennedy drop the l-bomb
way too early I thought I thought it
would have been one of those situations
much like jean-paul and you just send
them home and you're like okay
I'm not on your level and this is like
fraudulent so if she really I believe
that she does believe that she's falling
love with him because she's so [ __ ]
obsessed with him
yeah I think it's also it's a move now
like in bachelor world there's a couple
things you have to do in order to secure
the rose one is open up about something
about your past done to say you love
them yes but she she's being true for me
like about it which is making which if I
were holding I would say yeah you're
being too [ __ ] late about her not
like experiencing real emotions I would
have sent her home but whatever that's
just me
okay Colton is a lot of things and it's
doing a lot of things right but what
he's not doing is his what is annoying
me is like Kaitlyn was very like
cutthroat like if she was on a date with
someone in the middle it wasn't going
well by like she got through people fast
like he's only sending people home at
Rose ceremonies except for at least who
walked out at least who walked out no
when he was had a group date cocktail
party and he was talking to that girl
who was really pretty and should have
had no reason to um go home and she was
just being like boring and stupid he was
like I'm not feeling this I'm sorry I'm
really I must add up so I think that was
the episode that you guys it was a girl
who was just like all the other girls
like nothing and her conversation looks
like pseudo and I think she even said
something like you know I know I'm
supposed to open up but like I haven't
really like experienced and he was just
like I'm sorry I don't feel this
connection like you can go he's out I
think Colton is doing an incredible job
I'm gay he is he's just so hot um let's
talk about the elites of it all because
homegirl went in with a plan that
completely [ __ ] back all right her
plan was I'm gonna wear a wedding dress
in this say I can't get married to while
you're dating other people
so you should marry me right here right
now gorgeous give your services ordained
right and she was ready to get married
or she's not she wanted him to give her
something like to hold her over like how
Ben Higgins gave Lauren B that picture
of him you know
ya know she thought she needed a
proposal right then and a wedding right
then and there or I'll she was going
home and you know she didn't get what
she wanted it completely [ __ ]
backfired he was like okay let me walk
you out and she was like no I don't
wanna go home I was so I'm glad because
people were like thinking she was the
winner or that she would be bad tried a
b-bow a smidge no I saw a lot of talk
about it so now let's reevaluate I don't
want to say who I think wins because I
already know it was spoiled for me and I
don't spoil for other people but I do
think that actually now I'm not gonna
say who you think yeah so I'll say and
even
as if last night like Cassie and Colton
are definitely in love it was a little
too physical for a first date for me
they didn't talk when they did talk it
was like just talking about how into
each other's work what they it's like he
has with Cassie what he had with Hannah
a couple weeks ago he's a little lusty
so he could still turn into something
real and you know the psychic is you'd
say they were brother and sister in a
past life and that could mean something
um so she could win but I could also see
it not going further than where it is
which is just like totally physical also
she looks so different on TV than she
does on her Instagram look she gives us
such a different vibe on Instagram where
it's like fashion glamour and on TV
she's like cool girl chill you know hair
a mess in the water but I don't care
Becca Martinez I believe gave birth you
like to announce it on her Instagram um
probably cause like she's in the
maternity ward getting breast feeding
lessons so that's true I guess I guess
she's busy well congrats to her so who
would I pick for act rat maybe tisha
I like tisha a lot but don't tell me for
about checkers and although that they
don't win but we won um I just need to
think of some of the other girls Hannah
G is going straight to revolve and then
to Paradise oh my god straight to
Coachella she's taking the plane from
from la toilette it's like a Stepford
yeah and revolved a tiny little plane
that's like maybe going to Andy Lowe
yeah and she's going to the Merv Griffin
estate and you know nothing is gonna
stop her okay who else is there that is
decent who the [ __ ] is there I don't
wanna say people's names okay Heather
Kailen Kailen Oh maybe Bachelorette but
there's definitely something villainous
about her I don't know if they'll
address it or not but I don't think even
if they don't trust it I don't think
she'll be a Bachelorette if Hannah B is
Bachelorette I'm done with the franchise
um Tami fair backs right she would be
great god forbid they give the people
what they really want she is so funny
she's [ __ ] crazy but in the greatest
way in the greatest way like she is
someone that I want to be my friend I
will always be under it and you know
what it is like in a weird way she's so
like confident and she's really young
but she's like wise I agree they're
painting her out to be like crazy like
they did to Corinne but like Jamie is
there's more to tell me that me too she
is Korean you're like just like when you
meet her I'm sure she is just so cool
and funny and fun and she's just like
saying things not thinking of you know
how is this gonna sound he's gonna come
out she's like this is what I'm thinking
so I'm gonna say it um update on how to
jeez Instagram cuz the last time you
checked it was like 180 she's not for 12
when I check laughs great okay I'm
pushing for her for a million by the
time she goes home she has a dramatic
ending maybe she'll go home right at the
fantasy suite he'll be like I'm not
feeling it so what do you think they're
gonna do with the fantasy suite he's not
gonna sex with everyone I don't know
he's like being so much hornier than any
other bachelor can you imagine
what if he lost his virginity like in
the fantasy suite or not even in this
fantasy suite like with someone and they
spoke about it you know I don't think
it'll happen because I don't think he'll
have sex with two people on the show you
don't go from like zero do a hundred no
me neither
but let's that's with one person it'll
be so clear and I was the person who
went and if that person doesn't win the
person that he does propose she will
never forgive him I think he would be
very prudent of him to not have sex on
the show oh great because it'll just
ruin the way that it ends and I think
even still he doesn't know who it's
gonna be I think for a while he thought
it was Hannah gee like I'm just gonna go
through the motions with other people I
think right now he thinks it's Cassie
but he's been now giving Hannah Chi a
date next week so he can find out what
was really going on between them you
know everything up in the shower you
know what's so weird is like and this is
always what happens on the show like
everyone's sitting around one Cassie's
on her date let's do something you know
what enjoy um everyone Glen Cassie's on
her date everyone in the house is
freaking out there like Cassie is the
prettiest girl she's the best connection
to Colton like she is I mean like I miss
that whole thing yeah and sometimes like
when like when Lauren Burnham won
Ferrari you like saw it immediately
oh no sorry Lauren B run fur and then
you were like there's no way Lauren he's
not winning from the very beginning and
I literally was like who's Lauren be
like sometimes it goes over my head with
a cat like I feel like I've been really
in tune this season with the Cassie
thing everyone's talking about I'm like
what am i minutes they had one make out
against a window in a high-rise building
and it gave me an order and that was all
I saw however it is reminding me of
something at Olivia Kareem he once told
us I don't know who's on the show
yesterday where when they would travel
with The Bachelor Ben all of the girls
would have to interact with them at the
same time like he would always like
gravity and gravitate towards more and B
and like they all knew really early on
that it was her because of those moments
that we didn't see yes assuming that's
what was happening here but I
Griet like I never thought Cassie was
outstanding other than the fact that
they always play romantic music for her
yeah they want us to see her as a real
contender okay um yeah I was just like
what I'm like well maybe he was episode
I miss like I didn't even know I forgot
about her like legit cuz now I'm like
thinking of her in a different light and
I'm looking at her Instagram like damn
she's beautiful but before I was like
wow she literally is just like textbook
bachelor contestant yeah you know there
was like nothing blond girl from
California outstanding about her or her
package or anything completely okay I'm
glad I didn't miss something yeah
exactly I do I felt the same way
great but now she's obviously on my
radar so I'm gonna make a top-three
prediction okay Cassie oh you know what
actually she's stressing out maybe I'm
not maybe top 4 okay okay Cassie who did
Jimmy Kimmel pick as a wave watch
because I saw someone commented I don't
want that Jimmy Kimmel's has to read
reality sleeps and then I was like oh
whoever he picks there's no way he
always knew after the first we watched
Jimmy Kimmel and then I get like that's
what I go off of but he was really wrong
last time so I'm saying Cassie
who do you see last time I think he said
that Becca that Becca one it means
technically not wrong no but I don't
even think he had Lauren B in the mix he
doesn't morality Steve no but for this
one it seemed like he was dead on
oh I'm saying Cassie honey G Taoiseach
and maybe Caitlin but he doesn't have to
read reality Steve he's on the network
some will just tell it right but the
comment made me think that whatever he
said was why would it stars a Liam I'm
going Cassie Hannah G Tasha
Kailyn for top four agreed I'm not I'm
really not sure about how did she any
more I think her date next week is gonna
go really well
oh I forgot she's up to date one she
gets an a weeks yeah and then she has
two more weeks yes I think it's until
hometown yeah maybe okay III think
that's a strong I really liked Asia oh
I'm fine like someone was finally like
but she onika she was like I was lonely
there for that conversation like Nicole
did not say that and I felt really bad
for Nicole but Sheila couldn't defend
herself like she's not made for reality
TV like what that girl did Anika is that
her name onion whatever I cared
literally hiding out and Yan's name she
goes to Colton in the thirstiest most
losery way I wanted to slap her upside
the head first of all what does that
even
mean get out of Miami she acts like she
lives in Arlington Iowa right Miami's a
bustling metropolis totally like she can
get on a plane just like she came to LA
for the show right she could get out of
Miami was talking about that like Nicole
can you elaborate on what you meant by
that
you know right but she was just like I
heard it from Elise and it's like diddly
start stuff on her way out the door
because like I respect even if I believe
start it up on her right out the door
weird to start at about a girl who
literally has no connection with Colton
and is very obviously not going anywhere
like it was just weird drama to start
and honestly I was really feeling like
onika was a girl who was I don't think
she I didn't think Elise is starting
drama I thought that uh Onika was
because tisha was there too and T she
didn't interpret it that way right but
and good for chase you for being like I
was literally there she didn't say that
but also good for tisha for not going to
Colton and writing that wrong because
it's not your [ __ ] business and do
not you don't want to have that smell on
you but being a girl who starts drama if
I were in the house and someone like
went to Colton about me and he told me
or something I would be like okay
regardless of oh there's true or false
then it'd probably be false because I'm
a great gal I would be like okay so how
was your day like I wouldn't even pay
why mine these girls like they dig their
own graves by being so like so almost
like insecure like if you know like you
defend about you and you know that
wasn't you and be like oh that never
happened but I'm sorry that she you know
feels I need to do that anyways what's
going on with you that's how you play
guys Nicole did such a horrible job for
a million reasons like one she literally
couldn't get words out like I think she
cries to all the girls and then can't
muster up a tear for Colton drinking so
fake cry and then being like it's like
you know that if you say the word bully
like you automatically win a fight it's
like a buzz word like that because like
bullying is not allowed anymore
and not that it really ever was but like
now it's a buzz well no it used to be a
rite of passage right now it is for
Bettina so she's like I've been building
and Colton has to send Onika home now
like it was a brilliant move but it was
so strategically like she looked so fake
like she was just like she did such a
poor job but then only cos like I mean
like I hate that I'm ik sitting here
talking Colton like I've had a cold like
I want to talk about us first of all
let's do Darius sing of all you can't
start a [ __ ] fire and then want to know
why everyone's talking about the [ __ ]
fire you bragging started that was
Hannah beam right you can't take a big
steaming dump in the middle of a room
and then ask everyone why they're asking
why it smells you know mm-hmm so I hope
they both go home because as much as
Nicole was really the victim here she
played so poorly like I would just hate
her now she could have turned it around
and minute champion but she turned she
was a loser so her paw cut her chin
knocker broke what's her name someone
kirpa Kiernan pyramid
Kiernan cut her chin by slipping on
Romney and I take a picture I don't know
I just said Karen I'd literally kept
here one sharp cut that's why we keep
[ __ ] it up I can't remember anyone's
name in last night I was thinking I'm
like doesn't usually take me this long
total remember people's names usually
I'm better about the names like the fact
that I can't remember the name of the
girl who I'm II wonder why there's
somebody that like interesting more
dynamic names usually it's like Hannah
Ashlee Sarah like Kaelyn is an
interesting name Yakka interesting name
yeah Kiernan Shipka interesting name
finally it's not just like Hannah Lauren
Ashley
I mean it's Hannah G Hannah be Jessie I
was about to call her Kalle today
because he was telecasted a it says your
names well now that I recaps done we
have five minutes left you do an
in-depth interview with a nephew sneeze
Ches Oh doctor it was kirpa kirpa okay
so we were like half right
ya know what did we said you said
Kiernan yeah here is your pika I'm sorry
all these blonde girls I Caribbean
responsible for their name sorry Cassady
and I'm sorry when there's Kiernan
Shipka out in the world and he's just
like taking the world by storm and and
your name is a conflation of the two
kirpa yeah it's tough for us so yes
Cassidy had a great one-on-one lesson
okay obviously I thought her name was
Cassidy this whole time dr. Theodor for
Chapman oh no you are I'm gonna I'm the
review time I'm the interviewer here
good morning Theo how was your little
nap that you took when you finally
became a good boy it was good I think he
looks really well rested and ready for
this interview okay so Theo a lot of has
been made and a lot has been said about
your journey to this country from Russia
are you here legally I can neither
confirm nor deny that I understand and
so you have this iconic babushka that
you wear that really has become a symbol
and an icon and a beacon of hope it was
my great-grandmother's and how many of
those do you own just the one just the
one and how often do you wash it like
your mom never five days a week I wash
my babushka when I feel it is necessary
that is none of your business
I'm also British did you pick up the
accent on your way crossing from Russia
it was a long long journey
so then what what fueled you are really
inspire
to get into the medical field like where
did that decision come from on my
journey to America I met so many
wonderful people who helped me that I
was so inspired I wanted to help others
and how do you feel about grown women
visiting a pediatrician in their in
their late 20s early to mid late 20s I
say it is okay I have patients from all
around the world different ages
different sizes different genders I
don't care a doctors love knows no
borders no boundaries
are you part of the coalition of Doctors
Without Borders interesting fact that is
well interesting I founded Doctors
Without Borders well I mean how could
you are the doctor and you have no
borders no bodas Jackie
none so how do you feel I know you've
hired a new brand manager for your
Instagram so that you can attract new
patients and really inspire more people
by your inspiring story how do you feel
that this new agency is doing on your
page you feel well represented these
agency is very expensive and honestly I
am not seeing results well I have a
statement here from the agency
hahaha I thought a my chair okay as an
agency we are so honored and privileged
to be working with dr. Theodore for
chairman and helping to bring and shed
light to his amazing work however we
feel we are grossly underpaid grossly
underappreciated and all we need not
monetary compensation is just a nephews
love once more what do you have to say
to that I also have a statement here
that reads go [ __ ] yourself
stop trying to monetize off of my
precious face
well we they had a feeling you were
gonna say that so they do they send
another statement okay Wow look at
worked up videos getting Wow Theo just
Wow Wow
we have been working day in and day out
to help you monetize your brand so that
you can help put some [ __ ] food on the
table for your parents and for all of
your various aunts and uncles who just
want the best for you and we have been
providing for you
it's time that you use that beautiful
face in that beautiful mind to provide
for others but an Theo's final statement
ease your fire you'll see you'll all see
I'll go to a different Cavalier you'll
see oh please there's nobody as cutest
Thea on the Internet
I'll make them cute actually cavalier
pixel is really [ __ ] huge yeah and
[ __ ] Ness of the cavalier Nessa no
she's so cute and pure and her eyes are
so big - cutest e oh my hand smells I'm
so sorry for you but that was really fun
well this is just a week a week of such
good guests because not only to be of
the world renowned founder of Doctors
Without Borders dr. Theo for chairman
tomorrow we have Jackie and Jennifer the
two new housewives from Real Housewives
of New Jersey we will put up a picture
on her and ceramic please flood with
comments I have so many but I think I
want the people's the people's questions
you know the people's couch the people's
questions can't wait for it can't wait I
have such a busy week so I've gotta go
we've already went out where oh me too I
have got to get a gown I'm Cinderella
going to the ball and I need a gown you
need a fairy tails mother I think you
guys for being here on this 90-minute
show we're back tomorrow
new house in New Jersey we'll see you
then well me I'll check you uh problems
a pub with no job even though I was
fired but you know what I want to beg
for my job back